bonjour c'est les vacances de noël alors
comme à chaque vacances nous avons nous
proposons des films pour les enfants et
nous avons évidemment le vaiana le film
de disney nous aurons aussi
prochainement ballerina nous aurons
aussi la bataille géante de boules de
neige énormes qui sont les grands films
de la fin de l'année et bien entendu
nous ne passons pas à côté de rock one
que nous aurons en vf et en vo
nous avons aussi demain tout commence
avec omar sy et mon coup de coeur donc
ça sera manchester baïse aussi que nous
aurons la semaine du 4 janvier
manchester by the sea s'est réalisée par
kenneth lonergan c'est l'histoire de la
famille chandler qui lie est désigné
tuteur de son neveu patrick à la mort à
la mort de son frère et il se retrouve
confronté à un passé travail qui doit
retourner dans la ville où il a grandi à
manchester états unis
et ça lui complique un petit peu la vie
le réalisateur kenneth lonergan nous
fait passer toutes les émotions des
personnages de l'histoire par l'image il
ya quasiment aucun mouvement de caméra
il réfléchit chaque scène en fonction de
son espace et de la présence hinault de
ses protagonistes et donc nous autres
spectateurs ont c'est là qu'on ressent
vraiment l'isolément du personnage pour
pour moi et pour d'autres on pourrait
considérer que
manchester rises est peut-être l'un des
meilleurs films de l'année 2016 vous
retrouverez évidemment toutes nos
informations sur notre site internet
cinéma grenier à sel points quand je
sais alors
[Musique]